we'll choose if we have a tiebreaker
all right jalen green's got oh it's
put on no no no no i think duck's in
that is that like the flavor flavor
that's an nft but the duck with an nft
on
that thing flies and hits you in your
face be careful that's all i'm saying
gold chain with the nft pendant he's
playing his own highlights
bringing this into the modern day okay
say no more all about to say he's not
dunking i think he's going to just tuck
it on this jersey let's go who do you
give this to
isaiah yeah okay
put that in your pocket isaiah
i want to see a 50 i want to see him
come out and just
somebody's got to come out electrified
yeah we need that right now we need that
right now
[Applause]
[Music]
looks like he's going off
that was explosive
he's trying to hurt the rim things to
come here you're trying to hurt the rim
you know
which is not fair that's another story
john ross will be playing something
jaylen green coming out of the g-league
ignite
top-rated high school player
now with the houston rockets his first
dunk contest
oh
man and through his legs okay
that is tough
so the tell me here he still has three
attempts left he didn't have to control
the ball in the first two so
to be young needs the adrenaline see
i would need an er bed after that that
first attempt
he's got this one
he's got this you can see it you can see
it he's got this oh
his head you see his head he was there
he was there
he's speaking by the way jalen green was
born in 2002
there it is oh it looked
oh you know what that floor is sticky
you know why because i was able to touch
the backboard no i was like y'all
[Applause]
we just need you to go dunk one baby
remember back in the day in the gun
contest we had the time limit
with my guy birdman did it about six or
fifty times
he loses he's losing the judges fellas
yeah yes all he got to put it in and
isaiah is putting that thing around his
neck
oh my goodness we gotta change it up
taking a big bite trying to take a big
bite
you're going to do it he's still going
to do it
[Music]
remember when nate took a while he
he also won three times what do you
think do you think
do the same dunk
without without without going through
your letter no no i'm throwing it
because the scores are not outrageous he
can get eight to nine
there you go there you go oh just a
regular lob and it works and green's got
one in the books gotta give them some
some eights and i get them seven seven
and eight yeah
seven and eight
thirty nine or forty look at that look
at shaq
jack this is this is shaq's pet peeve
when guys take this long but look at his
head though oh god i mean
he could have just came out and did that
right away just yep that would have been
great
warm up 45 yes move on
see he should have read
the landscape of the room all i need is
a 45. yeah he's just done that dunk
right there
but
the problem is
he thought that first dunk was easy for
him
and it wasn't oh because you're in eight
to
got one more dunk club remember he had
the first two dunks
top two make it to the finals
top two
toad got cold cole's got to bring out a
50. so cole anthony got it started with
a 40.